- Le moment est solennel.La vics
savoureuse pour Joe Biden que
la bataille a été difficile.
Une longue marche vers le podium
avec la vice-présidente,
Kamala Harrionononon n'avait pas
vue depuis longtemps.
Leur relation serait tendue,
mais peu importe ce qui se dit
dans les coulisses, aujourd'hui
est une journée de célébration :
le projet de loi sur
l'infrastr v v v va
enfin devenir loi.
"Grâce à cette loi,
dit le président, pour
la première fois en 20 ans,
l'infrastructure américaine va
se développer plus rapidement
que celle en Chine. On aura
les plus belles routes,
ponts et aéroports d'ici
la prochaine décennie."
Et l'administration Biden aura
miueueueueuet, 1200 milliards $,
qui comprend 100 milliards
pour l'accès à Internet,
111 milliards pour l'accès
à l'eau potable, après
lanananananation au plomb
du réseau d'eau potable
de la ville de Flint.
Bref, on ne lésine pas sur
les coûts, l'infrastructure
du pays a besoin de sérieuses
rénovations face à des routes,
des ponts, des aqueducs
en décrépitude.
"Tous les États, rouges
et bleus, se sont ralliés",
dit-il. Joe Biden a gagné
son pari d'être un rassembleur.
"C'est crucial pour des gens
comme moi, dit ç ç ç ç ç ça va
créer des millions d'emplois."
Puis le moment tant attendu...
La signature du président.
Démocrates et républicains
célèbrent ensemble un projet
de loi qui a failli être rejeté,
si ce n'était de l'appui
de 13 républicains à la Chambre
ésésésésésésésentants.
"Ceci devrait être le début
d'efforts renouvelés pour
le bien du pays."
t t t t t t t voté en faveur
du projet sur l'infrastructure
ont subi l'ire de Donald Trump,
certains ont même reçu
des menaces de morts anonymes.
Il reste maintenant pour
l'administration Biden le projet
de loi sur les réformes sociales
et l'environnement, qui divisev.
"Le Congrès doit faire passer
ce projet de loi", rappelle
Kamala Harris.
Avec cette loi sur
l'infrastructure, Joe Biden
espère remonter sa cote de
popularité. Le dernier sondage
indique que 63 % des Américains
considèrent qu'il n'a pas
accompli grand-chose en
dix mois. Ce soir, il participe
à un sommet virtuel avec le
prés X X X X X X X Xi Jinping,
où il sera question entre autres
d'économie et de technologie.
La Chine, qui était toujours
dans la mire des États-Unis...
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Washingto